I want to start out with a quote I love
the way that you think and I'm curious
what you have to say about this the
quote is from American writer Don
DeLillo and he says the writer is the
person who stands outside Society
independent of affiliation and
independent of influence writers ought
to stand and live in the margins and be
more dangerous do you relate to the sort
of thinking I grew up in an artist my
artistic family both my grandparents
were my grandfather's one was a painter
the other one was a film director and I
think there was a sense of the it's the
kind of anti bourgeois attitude at the
same time I'm working with movies
stories about people and I think the
only way to have a nuanced specific
relationship to my characters that I
write is to live as well you know and
not to be an outsider in the sense of
living in a wood or being secluded but
rather to be in life and let it inspire
me as well but I'm interested in is
there such a thing as autonomy for
artists today in a commercial medium
like cinema are we allowed to think
radically through our movies my
perspective on that since you're
bringing up DeLillo is that it's through
the formal elements or how we tell the
story how we get people involved in
characters what images we show is where
we can hopefully bring some originality
and to bring something specific and
bring something philosophical yet have
characters that are real people you know
that that would be my ideal so you want
to be more in in the mainstream or or
not so much in the margins although a
lot of your film center on loneliness is
the filmmakers journey lonely
paradoxically I don't find the
filmmakers journey lonely I find it to
be a great collaborative thing this is
why I guess but obviously also because
I'm not that talented writer but why I
haven't chosen to write novels I love to
be with people I love to be with the
actress the team to create something
together I even write with a co-writer
called SQ folk to have made three
feature films with now so yeah I'd like
that I like the collaborative thing
yet I I think you are on to an
interesting point which is the fact that
if art becomes just the expected and
doesn't challenge the audience in any
way or challenge our notions of things
it could become rather uninteresting I
understand that you had looked at
several American scripts before
co-writing louder than bombs what was it
about the American stories that I I mean
I get it but I didn't that didn't sort
of resonate with you why I think it was
lessened so I read around a lot of
scriptures were generously offered to me
after I did my first film reprise about
10 years ago eight years ago I think
it's not the cultural thing I love
American centum I grew up watching
american movies i think it was more the
fact that through that process I
realized how personal I needed to be to
want to spend 23 years of my life doing
a feature film you know it's can be a
tough job sometimes and you know I'm
very grateful I'm allowed to shoot films
but there needs to be some thematic
structure some theme some characters
that I really deeply care about and it
turns out I I'd like to create those
myself I'm not saying I'll ever do
someone else's script but I don't think
it's a cultural thing I actually grew up
in Norway where most people know how to
speak English fairly well and I grew up
watching a lot of American movies so I
feel strangely at home in this culture I
don't I don't know what the explanation
is maybe it's woody allen or something
everything I learned from life and learn
from Woody Allen I think you also
mentioned that you loved The Breakfast
Club which I know for our generation is
sort of this you know turning point
known John Hughes movies for you now
what do you feel about television do you
feel a lot of character and and great
writing has emigrated to television and
has been left behind in film i watch TV
shows I think there's a lot of good
stuff going on I still feel field in
movies are vibrant and equally
interesting as ever so I think it's it's
kind of the wrong thing to put it up
against each other I'm glad that you can
we can have something like the wire
which is remarkably original and
insightful and beautiful and could only
work on
format of a TV show at the same time I'm
glad to see cinema developing year by
year and a new stores being told they're
so I I'm kind of slightly tired of the
dichotomy of TV and movies where we're
being inspired by each other and you see
a lot of great filmmaker personnel do TV
shows I'm carry out we just spoke about
Woody Allen he's doing a TV show they
tell me great I'll watch that you know
so but but I personally I love the big
screen I shoot on 35 I'm interested in
going you know the idea of watching
films together with other people i love
that personally when you work with your
DP how do you formulate and think about
where to place the lens in terms of
creating that sense of loneliness that
sense of isolation are there certain
ways that you feel the lens should be
placed to convey that sense of bleakness
because there's a lot of emotion and
feeling where you can see it in the way
that it's placed in terms of the
isolation of the moment I think you're
asking them almost a most central
question of all which is how do you look
at something as a filmmaker how do you
look at people where do you place your
camera why is there such a different
emotion when someone's sitting up
against the wall or up against the
window and all these things that are
really hard to intellectualize about and
they're quite instinctive it's almost
like the musical or poetic group if you
want to use those words you know the way
of making movies it's how you shoot the
missile sent to use the pretentious
French word that I love so the idea of
how to shoot is something I think you
develop and becomes a very personal as a
filmmaker and I work with yacov era a
wonderful semi tog referred that I
actually went to film school woods we
worked for I don't know 15 years
together and um yeah it's a hard
question to add to to answer why and how
we do our thing you know I think it's
really um but it's an essential question
I hope the answer lies in our movies
beautiful film thank you for making
thank you so much thank you okay great
what wonderful questions oh thank you
okay I start eating
okay yeah it's great that I get that
quote boys because it don't really look
such a smart man so I think it was
actually a sorry lucky so the artist has
no affiliation stops I'm sorry yeah all
right are we doing good right okay I'll
slow down a little I've had a lot
exciter excited i'm very excite okay
great all right